con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas y nos centramos en el
Consejo de Seguridad esto en el marco de
la asamblea general número 77 que tiene
lugar en Nueva York y donde varios
mandatarios han hablado de una
modificación de ese consejo esto
impulsado durante la inacción en la
guerra en Ucrania saludamos a Jesús
Manuel Pérez Triana analista de
seguridad y defensa autor de guerras
posmodernas.com y flanco sur.com Jesús
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 Qué pasa
al interior del Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU porque en esta asamblea general
varios mandatarios han apelado digamos
van propuesto han puesto la carta sobre
la mesa de un posible una posible
modificación a este Consejo de Seguridad
incluso pues dejar entrar a países de
América Latina y África como lo dijo el
presidente de Estados Unidos
la cuestión aquí fundamental Es que la
arquitectura internacional es el
resultado es
del fin de la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
tiene un consejo de seguridad donde hay
cinco potencias que se consideraban
fueron consideran las cinco potencias
ganadoras de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
Aunque el papel de china y Francia es
secundario frente al de otros Pero bueno
total tenemos un consejo de seguridad
con cinco miembros permanentes con un
poder de veto esto significa que cada
vez que se debate que se tiene que tomar
una decisión sobre asuntos que afectan a
los intereses estratégicos de algunos de
estos países pues tienen la capacidad de
vetar desbloquear cualquier decisión en
la época de la vieja guerra fría entre
el fin de semana mundial y la guerra
Berlín Pues estaba clarísimo cuando
había un asunto que afectaba al bloque
occidental ahí estaba en Estados Unidos
reunir de Francia para bloquear
cualquier iniciativa que lanzase el
bloque soviético si había cualquier
iniciativa que aceptar a los intereses
es lo que soviéticos que luego se
dividió China y unión soviética pues ahí
estaban Entonces tenemos un mundo que ha
cambiado tenemos un mundo multipolar Hay
un montón de países emergentes que ahora
tienen un papel mayor cada vez más
protagonista pense en el caso de la
India pensemos pues todas las economías
de asiático pues hacemos latinoamérica
que no tiene voz en ese consejo bueno y
el futuro también nos hablará de África
y países entonces da la sensación de que
es una mesa en la que se toman
Decisiones Con unos poderes
extraordinarios que se le han dado a
unos países en un mundo que ha cambiado
por completo claro ahora sobre todo el
papel de Rusia por eso digamos el
consejo de seguridad de la ONU no ha
tomado cartas en el asunto en esta
invasión porque Rusia tiene este poder
de Beto y porque por supuesto se pone en
contra de cualquier decisión que quiera
tomar este consejo de seguridad también
a lo mejor Cómo hacer para de alguna
manera pues expulsar o poner de lado a
Rusia en cuanto a esta decisión que tan
difícil puede ser esto y que puede hacer
la ONU para realmente tomar cartas en el
asunto en esta guerra
pues es muy complicado porque aquí lo
que estamos hablando al fin y al cabo es
de ceder en privilegios es decir tenemos
a cinco países que son Estados Unidos
son Unidos Francia China y Rusia que
además un potencial es que tienen un
privilegio especial tiene ese poder de
Beto entonces cualquier decisión que se
haga de meter más miembros permanentes
en esa mesa además están los cinco
permanentes que tienen que propósito
abierto y luego hay unos que van rotando
Entonces siempre se ha dicho que
deberían menos aunque no tengan
capacidad de vector debería haber
vosotros países que tengan
asiento permanente y claro al final la
decisión gira en torno a la idea de
quién cede quién renuncia a su
privilegios porque nadie quiere hacerlo
y además estoy seguro de que si Reino
Unido a Francia y Estados Unidos
plantean quitarle privilegios a Rusia
china va a pensar Bueno y quién me dice
a mí que yo no voy a hacer el siguiente
en la lista quién me dice a mí que
cualquier modificación cualquier cosa
por muy indignados que estemos con la
invasión rusa de Ucrania en el futuro
cualquier otra medida que afecta también
pensemos generado chino pues no van a
estar disponible Entonces eso es muy muy
muy complicado porque aquí estamos
hablando de qué países que tienen
heredaron un privilegio en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial ahora los cedan para
compartir el poder porque al fin al cabo
de lo que estamos hablando aquí es de
compartir el poder en un mundo que no
tiene nada que ver la verdad que sean
acrónico Porque esos privilegios se
ganaron en la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
el mundo que en el que vivimos y al que
llevamos es completamente diferente
entonces yo lo veo muy muy complicado
porque se trata de pedirle a países que
tienen un privilegio que lo sean Y eso
va a estar muy muy complicado de que
genere
en cambios reales al final posiblemente
lo más sencillo sea pues así poner
miembros permanentes sin privilegios sin
poder de Beto ampliar ese consejo de
seguridad pero que sean los países que
ya tienen ese poder de Beto ese poder lo
veo muy muy complicado Jesús Entonces
cómo queda el papel de Naciones Unidas
en conflictos tan importantes como la
guerra en Ucrania
Pues ahora lo que vamos a ver entonces
que volvemos a una época de bloques de
política de bloques donde el Consejo de
Seguridad va a ser inoperativo porque
vamos a ver que todo lo que afecte a la
Esfera china en el sudeste asiático y en
la Pues en la nueva ruta la seda en la
ruta y en la franja que están
construyendo los chinos que tienen un
montón de intereses múltiples pues cada
vez que hay algo se afecta a esos
intereses pues china vetará Rusia tiene
intereses en todo lo que es el cinturón
euroasiático vemos que ha tenido un
papel más protagonista y más
intervencionista desde conflictos en
África
Siria vemos que tiene el patio trasero
en el caucaso pues veremos que cualquier
cosa que se quiera tomar una decisión al
respecto pues ahí estará en Rusia para
bloquearlo y ojo que tampoco estamos
poniendo como China y Rusia los malos
porque eso ya lo hemos visto también con
Estados Unidos y por ejemplo en las
cuestiones que tienen que ver con Israel
entonces un mundo multipolar no es
necesariamente un mundo más democrático
en el que todo el mundo tiene vos no
sino que simplemente es muchos actores
tomando decisiones en su esfera y viendo
como instituciones como Naciones Unidas
inoperativas porque va a haber ahí un
choque de poderes que se van a
equilibrar y van a ser absolutamente
inoperativos entonces la asamblea
general se tomarán debatirán los asuntos
en el Consejo de Seguridad se tratarán
pero que se tomen decisiones que cambien
las cosas sobre el terreno dejar menos
desde la ONU va a ser muy complicado una
modificación podría ser no sé quitarle
peso a este poder de Beto o hacerlo Pues
es de otra manera para que no sea solo
un país el que tenga digamos esta
decisión pues esto tiene que ver con lo
que dije antes es decir tiene sentido de
que quitemos los privilegios heredados
de la Segunda Guerra Mundial porque ya
estamos en El Siglo 21 y ya vamos pues
ya han pasado bastante años es decir
demos ya de superar incluso la vieja
guerra fría queda muy atrás pero claro
le estamos pidiendo esos países que
tienen un privilegio que lo cedan y
entonces yo van a ser tan generosos que
van a renunciar van a decir Bueno vamos
a renunciar al privilegio de bloquear
las medidas que afectan a mis intereses
yo lo veo muy muy complicado es decir
porque no creo que estos países estas
potencias vayan a renunciar a ese
privilegio que puede ser arbitrario que
puede ser anacrónico pero es un
privilegio y es un poder que es muy
difícil que se dan y que al que
renuncien se puede expulsar a Rusia de
la ONU
muy muy complicado entre otras cosas
porque es una cuestión numérica decir
aquí en la opción de la Europa
occidental vemos el tema de Ucrania como
algo muy cercano vemos a Rusia
claramente estamos apoyando Ucrania pero
si uno mira en cuestión de números los
países de latinoamérica de África del
sudeste asiático repúblicas soviéticas
Oriente medio incluso aliados de Estados
Unidos no consideran que el tema de
Ucrania sea central en sus intereses
algunos han distanciado por ejemplo el
caso de Arabia Saudita que es un Aliado
muy cercano en Estados Unidos Oriente
medio piensa ha declarado Que bueno que
el tema de la conflicto Ucrania piensan
tener un papel neutral de hecho ha sido
importante el papel de Arabia Saudita
como mediador para la liberación de
prisioneros ayer y entonces no no parece
que occidente tenga el peso numérico en
Naciones Unidas claro para poder
expulsar y Porque además siempre
necesita el presidente porque siempre la
idea de los perros a los pequeños países
Estos son si estos se lo están haciendo
a Rusia que es una potencia nuclear yo
que soy pequeñito lo que me harán a mí
en un futuro entonces va a ser muy muy
que suben la cifra y que se puedan sumar
occidente y sus aliados poder suficiente
para hacer un movimiento tan tan simple